what's going on there reject nation we're
gonna watch the next episode all of us are
dead episode seven today what i asked right
now was you take a bite into that like button
as always full length watch alongs where you
sync up with the time code for all of us are
dead or over at our patreon page cover a whole
bunch of stuff over there special thanks to
all the become superior jacks and of course
the boys at prepper thanks for helping us
edit out these highlights like that bite into
you let's get to
it
speak of the devil
there might be students at the school but
let's start with them all
what
a great shot god damn you're not like all
the other soldiers back at the bow that's
why you're on the a-team quarantine kid
uh he'll be a special zombie
whoa
maybe that's why his son was like kind of
going back and forth for a bit
did he swim under water that whole time he's
been holding his breath since last episode
he's going to misinterpret all this as something
sexual then
oh buddy i thought he made that pretty clear
i was gonna say just make it to him
perfect
people are going to think
she's trying to eat him though
my man get that get that kiss give her one
back
[ __ ] yeah that's what i'm [ __ ] talking
about man
so superpower
she if they have that level of super hearing
couldn't they hear anyone
oh my
god
teach a girl to fish to eat forever that looks
like she ate a real fish
foreign
feed
i don't know why that one was especially gross
yeah well she knows what she's doing
maybe hamby's can't eat people
oh my gosh she's gonna grab his guts and eat
some more then just vomit right into the cavity
oh she's gonna hear her in the closet isn't
she yeah that's what i thought she first heard
uh
damn i want to get [ __ ]
you're not the boss anymore dude
we're best friends man oh
what's up
now
gnarly
street smarts bro
dude i'm riser secret out of here man you
just gotta
couldn't you skip the protocols at least once
oh yeah
oh my god he's asian joel from the last of
us all of the last of us are dead
now
this is the video game action episode be the
quiver my dude
that baby's just gonna be all taped
like a mummy baby
they are children
excellent
these two are my favorite odd couple
i i doubted for a second there
he's that dedicated
hop in the chicken trunk
this guy's a really good guy he's the best
guy we all deserve him looking for us in the
zombie apocalypse
oh dude
well that holds
and then i stabbed him in the eye
that is
reputation proceeds
go beat with your love
that does not seem stable
work those pipes my guys
oh in the end music's safe
that's crazy
god such cacophony there's no way what they
build could stop that matter
oh
he's dead either way ah man this guy's got
ethics which is all right
children are the future education knowledge
is powerful
they haven't even thought about the school
politeness fight do it just go
come on chung son go
please tell me you closed the door
sorry i gotta kill
god how did they do some of this
so they didn't close the door
i'm the only one left
oh god damn it
yes
dude just just unlock the door
don't be an [ __ ] open the damn door dude
dude
jesus christ open the god damn door
what the
dude that guy is pissing me off you better
open the goddamn door
oh jesus oh god
fire start a fire somehow
burn the zombies
dude open the door open the door
all right solid good call
this is so frustrating i haven't been this
upset in a while i just want to scream at
this kid
oh my god
wow
oh my god oh my god
all right next time somebody has to cut his
head all the way off
that's so frustrating no man i hate that guy
i can't decide if i hate the guy on the roof
more or if i hate queen anymore yeah it's
a great one it's a great conundrum i'm not
sure they both suck yeah jeez
then again like 99 of that school are horrible
people so you know it's just yeah i'm out
of the door with an [ __ ] well yeah the problem
is now if the door gets open then guinom will
inevitably get onto the chopper and be saved
alrighty yeah wow man that uh last few minutes
i was like i know they're not gonna open that
door and so on [ __ ] the cliffhanger they're
gonna do that cliffhanger [ __ ] yeah next
episode door's gonna fly right open a lot
of this theme dealing with uh the bullied
getting their their their payback even in
some ways guinom is bullied maybe bullying
begets bullying maybe yeah maybe the worst
bully is the bully who's like number two to
the main bully who gets bullied by the bully
and then becomes an even bigger bully because
yeah and then the ultimate bullied oonji will
now become the master bully killing everybody
yeah wow that's that's gnarly snarly stuff
so all right we got prez prez oh we got okay
lee sue and what's perez's name ramcha no
uh no namra nam ram jam ram bruh wow
stud muffin perez all out in
the open now i like them confessing their
feelings to each other for some reason i was
under the impression that she like really
did you that he made it clear already then
i was looking back on that headphone scene
and i realized oh he never actually said something
did he no no he's just putting vibes out i
could have sworn he like made it clear in
that scene and his whole time watching it
under the under the optics that he's already
established his feelings for her like we'd
know but i thought he i thought she already
knew so yeah that was really sweet scene and
now we're just building up some stuff that
has to pay off i like i like going back to
the quarantine zone where you're seeing like
okay some of these soldiers are not bad people
like even the main guy in charge who comes
across like an ominous douchebag when he's
tall and talk to assembly member woman about
how she won't get special privileges but he's
just being disciplined he's just being stern
but you can see he's a caring guy still a
little bit surprised the uh oblivious nature
of not even checking on schools obviously
yeah for that to be like the last thought
on everyone's mind i think is interesting
we haven't been anywhere near those places
yet sorry you mean the buildings where there's
hundreds to maybe thousands of students the
future
yeah we're just assumed that they were all
dead you know the worst place to go is to
a school because think about it the kids are
already there if the outbreak happens near
there then it's just gonna be overrun right
away there's no point even trying to go to
school i think this all started from a school
too yeah that was the last place they checked
even the schools bullying
yeah the students are going to stand up to
the soldiers at the end that's that's what
this is all about damn that's that's embarrassing
that's cool getting the caring side what i
think this show does really well is doing
a splice of like pretty much every type of
zombie property i've ever seen like that and
but in a way that enhances uh expands upon
and and i think um compliments and and sure
it shows it wears its love for the zombie
genre on his shoulder i think that's one of
the great things about it is it knows how
to be like a cool zombie show when you're
going to like the pob and the action action-driven
moments like there's a lot more action in
this episode than i think some previous episodes
they're more than just like thank god this
wasn't boring yeah um i think we're past that
part of when people said it was
so yeah that like this this uh like with the
pov of the gun play at the top of here uh
seeing firefighting dad breaking in grabbing
some weapons shocking and some people you
know or like getting on your bikes and heading
out like there's some real action moments
here that i thought were really cool like
i think like the love for the horror the action
and then realizing like how the zombie rules
really work and then also like taking full
advantage of it and watching those sequences
unfold like when the students are creating
this little barrier and using sound to bait
the zombies into their room and the way they
did that's think about the extras and the
background players and how uncomfortable of
a situation that is every horde scene i find
myself thinking okay now how many of these
bodies to the bottom of the frame must be
dummies in order for them to be crawling all
over each other and like it just it appears
as though i have no idea how a half of or
most of these extras aren't getting injured
seriously every time it looks like they would
be and i think that's part of the appeal of
the physicality that they realize here uh
so i'm enjoying that quite a lot and also
uh you know when it comes to even uh guinom
like i i really liked his scene a lot uh you
know like it gave me a different appreciation
for the character yeah when it's i'm not gonna
say he's a bully he's definitely not a bully
because that guy's mean to him i'm just saying
that that there's it at least gives an indicator
of something hurt and lost within him as a
child yeah that would allow him to succumb
to this other guy who's really like shorter
than him and like allows himself to be intimidated
by this dude but i kind of forgot that that
other guy calls the shots yeah yeah in that
moment i had to be like oh right that's their
power dynamic and it makes it so sinister
i you you said this last week and i think
it is important to touch on is as much as
that is a hateable character that guy's performances
are [ __ ] great because too just the way
that he has this very sort of like almost
lackadaisical way of looking at everybody
like he's so like just sort of like calm and
observant in the way he like has to be coaxed
into crawling under and you watch the gears
turn and you watch him like play with this
guy you know and and it's it's funny because
you know it to me it drew me in and i was
like was this what he was going to do all
along or is this more because he's realizing
at this moment like nah dude i don't i don't
need i don't have any kinship with you left
from the before times i i'm totally above
you as he says now well i think he's taking
his power like really this ever since he got
turned he's been all about mass consuming
and taking back power from wherever he felt
power was stripped from him taking out the
principle you know looks at his eye he wants
to use it has really offered chong's son and
he now that the guy who called the shots when
they're in the little bullying gang that they
had so i like the way they they brought i
like i really like the way they handle him
and and i think it's really cool where you
have stud muffin and chong son at the very
end there when the prior you have a scene
where they are talking about guinam and then
because because chong songs could have sworn
guinom died and then stunned muffin saying
you know no i saw him die he fell off the
floor and then they're both dealing with the
realization of oh [ __ ] this is worse than
hey like we're both right we're both right
and we're both way wrong this guy is worse
than all them and then i sure i'm sure it
creates some level of conflict too i i feel
like there's so many different directions
it can go with the situation like that of
and like i said i don't want to get too bogged
down in theorizing with the show that we're
just kind of going through really fast because
you know my mind starts to jump to the idea
of like well when you're presenting something
like that like maybe this guy has a cure that
we got to utilize so we can't just try to
kill him there's a lot of maybe we're going
to keep him alive like i feel like there would
be some type of debate uh so yeah just kind
of leave it at that because i'm sure we'll
get that answered in like five minutes in
the next episode so but it does make me really
curious and especially because you have this
this triangle of people with that gene of
like the only you have i love the polar uh
sort of opposites that yoonji and guinom are
because you know even though in social situations
they are literally the opposite it almost
makes you wonder if that gene is somehow linked
to just a certain sense of anguish or something
because you know maybe not as much with nom
robert those are two like very tortured characters
who are now being at polar opposites of the
human social spectrum are now sort of in the
same plane which is just fascinating to me
but um yeah yeah that's true and also i'd
say with uh omg i i like how she's coming
into uh this like new level of revenge and
confidence as well like she could just take
all these people out and i'm so glad our main
players were but it kind of goes back to like
her character is the living formation of what
science dad who created all this was uh kind
of motivated by you know like i was about
to say out loud that the students at least
didn't bully on ji but then they were also
complicit in the nature of they never they
never did anything yeah they never intervened
they never really tried to help so by its
association but the transitive property of
this it would stand to reason that like no
one matters to her anymore you know and then
yeah with namra you're a it's i'm curious
with the level of consciousness is on this
because clearly they have this like enhanced
sensory experience perhaps with they really
established it with hearing they didn't really
establish it with i mean with like yeah maybe
it talks about about oh no she doesn't smell
like nothing i've ever smelled before that's
true that's true yeah but it seems like the
most persistent is the sound yeah so it's
it's to me i'm like well now you could use
her to like navigate your way through like
everywhere she's gonna snuck out using her
stuff yeah you guys alright go yeah i'm gonna
snuck out if you if she learned to you know
hewn i said the word he did her abilities
so my curiosity though is like what is the
level of logic or awareness that can override
desire like will she still get filled with
a need to feed and then have to just give
in to that or can she just like talk herself
out of doing something you know yeah like
so it can can it be overridden with enough
willpower and and what is the need to feed
in that state because there's at least that
one bit where yunji like pukes up all that
guy all of the guy she just ate but not the
fish well it seems like with this new um this
new hybrid or enhanced human discussion that
my mind's starting to think like okay is this
show headed down a path of like they're purging
the world and there'll be a new breed of humanity
just yeah super sensory humans who are are
semi-bloodlusty well they talked about the
white blood cells too so they're giving indication
that there could be a a version of curing
this to some extent and they are the three
the the few white blood cells yeah the answers
are all in that school they are they really
are so many of the answers the laptop the
origin of the outbreak yeah you know yeah
the potential literally everything is there
pretty soon they're gonna get to a dead end
with their soldier guy and they're like [ __
] we gotta go back to the school which i i
really appreciated those poor trails to like
that guy like he just chose to go out and
help and and yeah for as much like the system
fails us commentary as there has been i enjoyed
this episode brought at least some around
of like okay they are actually going to the
school okay they are actually kind of coming
up with in the moment reasons for why their
protocol is what it is based on the situation
here now versus you know in the previous episodes
so much has been about you know like these
are the protocols that we all adhere to in
normal society and you know yeah i i feel
like this is what being the third day now
or still maybe the second day like it all
feels like the the way they keep an eye on
like the geography of the progression of this
whole situation the way they choose to cut
around is really conscientious and just to
go back to something you said at the beginning
like i i do love the way that they'll take
you can tell that there's love for the zombie
genre throughout this because one of my favorite
aspects of the show's style is that it will
throw in various things that will slip past
you with and then in moments you'll go oh
that is like a classic zombie moment or classic
zombie movie trope but they're so good at
taking that love and then completely infusing
it with exactly what they're doing here so
it only in the moment it just feels like it's
of the piece and you realize oh wow there
is like so much of the lexicon of zombie stuff
in here and even breaching into video like
this episode a ton of video game stuff like
when he's in the uh aside from like the mall
shootout sequence in the beginning like even
when firefighter dad is in the police station
i was like this is just like a resident evil
game you know you gotta like open the cabinet
and like you know you got zombies bursting
in like they're they're really good at yeah
spreading it around and never feeling like
oh this is one show and this is another show
like they all feel really well unified yeah
very true and then uh we got the cop guy too
cop guy and the influencer reminds a copy
reminds me a lot of my uncle danny shouts
out to my uncle danny dude looks a lot like
him and uh yeah i really love him a lot because
he he come he can when he first introduced
him he really came across like some hard ass
dude who and he is but he didn't he i just
never expected that the more you hang out
with him the more just like he really cares
about saving people so much like he is the
best guy because which is yeah no keep it
nice you got it no because that's such a like
it's such a great juxtaposition from how they
uh introduced him because because even though
you know dad dad is responsible and thus loses
certain amounts of sympathy you are really
pitted to expect him to be an antagonist at
the outset and and yeah it's like looking
back on that ideological debate it's like
oh yeah maybe i was the wrong guy to have
that debate with because this does seem like
one of the good ones out there this guy you
know and it makes sense that the other guy
seoul university would abandon him they set
that up like a gazillion times that he was
just on his way to not be with him even though
cop guy saved him yeah some gratitude you
guys some gratitude but like dude seoul university
you can't take care of [ __ ] the little girl
and the baby you're too weak well that was
the other thing i was like he just he just
sped off and i'm like what is he just gonna
like toss the baby toss the girl and go or
shove the girl in the trunk and go and they
did confirm the mom is dead for chong son
yeah that sucked the special zombie jeans
for her that's too bad you thought the chicken
in her blood that's never her msg shields
you from the disease unfortunately not but
here we are that was really that was really
well well done i think every one of these
episodes is good the dislike any one of these
episodes this is a great zombie movie it is
great really long zombie movie no they expand
it out and then every time they like cut to
a new character they're kind of adding in
a new zombie type of movie is what they're
doing that love for zombie genre shows they're
like really throwing like they don't just
start off like let's try to establish a bunch
of different zombie movies at first they they
really like whenever you cut to a different
character they have a different kind of zombie
movie yeah and i think that's really cool
that they are doing that and i like that they
even included the evolution of a human zombie
hybrid or hobby or how they call it you know
being like if you want to go all out
and get some like
zombie creatures maybe not
in this season i don't
know how far they'll go but i feel like if
they does get another season like yeah dude
like the crazy zombie creatures now like yeah
another full monster route why not it's good
dogs zombie birds yeah bio creatures they
they can't you might as well they introduced
a zombie rat that was like the start of this
whole thing so let's go all out all right
guys well that's it for today thank you so
much for being here uh leave a like if you
can and last but not least we'll send this
off with a paper
deontay w tongue punch fart box i think you
know why you're getting the shout out today
we got not one but two close-ups on people's
fart boxes in this episode a lot of uncomfortable
sounds and i couldn't help but imagine to
myself we were trapped with deontay how much
more of that will we have to hear day in and
day out constantly trying to tolerate you
not throw you out to the zombies maintain
our humanity but then halfway through what
happens oh [ __ ] we found the solution what
can the zombies not take more than the absence
of human flesh an abundance of sulfuric fart
fumes from your fart box my friend and that's
the secret that's the solution you've saved
us all and here we were about to throw you
out to your death so deontay thanks for keeping
it real out there thanks for holding it down
and i hope you're having a good 2022 so far
all the love and stay farting